[Music]
nice to see you know it's nice to see
you looking's doctor contest we're both
happy to see each other I was told as a
contest Miami
it is not a consciousness happier to see
you have always had a nose for news
that's what I like to say I do yeah yeah
yeah you know over the years you're
always scouring the paper looking
furnishing stories what's a story that
you've really loved it's been in the
news since we last spoke with that a
little while that is a good question
Conan I do scour the papers what we do
this is my news telling story oh okay
pose right alright it looks like you
have fake ventriloquist legs that you're
moving around I better adjust this for
the storytelling part that's not even
real no it's not it's actually a blade
what's wrong with that
I don't know such a funny area so yeah I
do read the paper a lot i watch the news
but i'm my interest is piqued by certain
stories not like the stuff about the
pope and all that stuff you do on your
show what i like is
you didn't like my communique I didn't
say that I loved your comedic areas yeah
but I know you're gonna cover that yeah
so I look for the other things like the
guy who skydive from 24 miles up he went
to the Earth's atmosphere was crazy
crazy up in a ballon he had a spacesuit
made you know specifically for this dive
filmed it
he's free-falling for like 24 miles and
going very fast too faster than the
speed of sound
he's very fast yeah and glad his chute
opened up because if it didn't he would
have created quite a mess on the on
earth and you would not want to clean
that up and probably when they cleaned
it up afterwards they would have been
leaving they would hurt Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
never seen you act that much well now
you're a guy at a concert you're you
always come with do you see how
ambidextrous I am that was a news story
always thought you ready for the night
next story pose right here very nice you
always come with advice you know you
like advice you know you you you like
the advice yeah but here's the thing you
know you know me for a while yes I'm
very long time contra bait what's the
word I'm looking for
confrontational adverse you are averse
to combination confrontation yeah I
don't like even when someone's playing
Angry Birds I get uncomfortable yeah
because I want to work out I can't can't
be work it out you know I mean who the
bird birds the birds in the pigs can't
think work it out yeah okay I'm but let
me continue uh-huh so for me when I'm
like in traffic and I have road rage is
difficult for me to confront people so I
do it in my own way like I'm not I'm not
a fan of people texting in the car
because I think it's very distracting
it's illegal and people die from that so
if I'm at a stoplight and there's a guy
behind me I see him texting on his cell
phone I will back into him and then I'll
get out of the car go dude you hit me
when you're texting
[Applause]
yeah it's a great way to do it and then
not you know you get the guy that pulls
up next to you with a loud you know the
the stereo playing you know the bass
speakers hip-hop stuff and yeah I'm not
really a fan of that I want my quiet
time in the car you know why don't they
think we want to hear that music you
know and allowed this car shaken
sometimes I think I'd like to go home
and get like my favorite book and
highlight it and hold it up the window
front of him here read that here either
you like Nora Roberts don't you there
you go I'm not in the mood for reading
but there it is you know I mean it's not
it's exactly the same thing